Well, already,
I wanted to apologize not too much
to have made a video this week,
but there have been big changes
for the European elections.
So I had 2 meetings with most of the
all citizen movements in France.
So we made 2 meetings
where there were about 140 managers
and in relation to the urgency of the situation,
we are looking at how to make 1 koalition
and 1 common list for the European elections.
So there would be no more small parts
who would run individually,
but 1 big citizen coalition,
so that's what we're up to.
And in this collision,
there would be 2 stars that you know very well,
titips,
1 singer,
1 comedian
that I should meet.
So I'm going to Avignon today
to meet
all these citizen leaders
to make 1 common list.
Well, you know what?
I really have hope
because for the 1st time,
people would be able to put their egos aside
to gather,
and I say gather well,
not follow someone and get behind them,
but gather side by side.
So there is something very heavy going on for the
European
and I can already announce that I will do 1 live
by the end of April
with these 2 stars
where we will talk about the European elections,
of the different proposals
and the path we aim for.
It is 1 immense honor that has been done to us
to be able to be part of this coalition,
but in addition to being 1 driving element and engine
as I tell you,
I really have hope.